welcome back to exited hey hey nice
alright I skills me skills me coming
through
yes me oh that was your kid well that's
just too bad
all right let's find state oh oh I can
get snacks what are you looking at you
never seen a fish [ __ ] some sawdust
before here she is the dark sea whoa I
hate their scary is this game gonna be
ski they're gonna be Monster is coming
no items kidding it's me yeah this guy
I'm cool I'm cool as long as you cool
crayola the lecture than your money I
mean am i oh you have what it takes to
hunt in the darkness do we see these
moves do we see this move you see this
move oh do you see these moves girl do
you see this girl do you see this moves
girl oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god I'm the most Michael ishes guy in
the heaven
bring it on [ __ ] do you see this
[ __ ] move do you see this mic around
you girl Oh take a shake light and
descend god shut up you so annoying oh
my god fish can live forever
can they live get a room no no that's a
lie
don't believe everything you read in the
newspapers let's go down let's go down
baby girl oh my god it's a jellyfish I
try to eat a jellyfish once
it wasn't jelly why is there no one else
at this aquarium this is very unsafe why
what is it
Oh Oh what look at my sexy end this will
go up your buck if you don't [ __ ] off
hey go away little girl take it excuse
me this girl Oh nobody suspects a thing
all of jellyfish were you entranced
I bet you were that was great give me
the knife just give me the lies in the
bus and about what is this maintenance
no I'm not high
I am expert scientists okay just on
don't even talk to me unless you're
famous okay we got one and fene element
a we put that I do in that bowl come on
don't fight me
I'm not sure how I made that possible
I'm kind of stuck come on
I got damnit huh not again I wish life
wasn't so difficult there we go
where's number four no with Miss Lee
yeah
snuggle fish toy makes a killer gift
just like my deck ball and I'll delete
you say that all right that's like my
life right there finally some disco oh
[ __ ] this is gonna be tough I hate my
life
why no no don't die - need your help I
got this in the bag except that on I got
damn it now I was fly on the wings of
love okay I got it I got it just about
does it stop
Oh God God sign em up these are faster
than before yeah I got I got that I got
that the first one was hard enough okay
oh my god oh my god oh god oh god the
finger coordination that is required
it's like [ __ ] fingering okay nothing
okay you need it you need to step up
your game son you need a Oh Oh finger
please no more please don't mark please
shut up shut up and let me rest okay I'm
nervous it's gonna be another one around
the grunting deep ocean what are you
Holland delighted I bet you were
I did no puns no more puns man Oh what
do we got here what I don't st. [ __ ] but
hey let's go to that beer hey girl
what's up
I Sakura
that's [ __ ] trap man
oh god either Gwen who run this time so
that's how it looks like I'll tell your
family the bad you know I'm in prison
come on how did he escape the first time
Octopussy
oh he's reminiscing Susan he says arisen
it's a bit sick
oh so this is this is how we did it
first time okay
you know him I'll be taking a shower in
the middle of a rainstorm ha ha ha
hey mad house good house good guy I
would be so [ __ ] scared
[ __ ] I can hide in these ok dad I get
up I hope they will explain how the [ __ ]
I I got a wife and kids that's the real
mystery honestly
god I hate stairs oh it's not it's not
bad i fat ok I got a balanced one oh no
you're right I'm in trouble I look like
a banana what the [ __ ] happened oh god
oh god this is really hard man smack
okay I did it
holy [ __ ] oh that [ __ ] joke man not
to banana peels anything that appeals
or the sued the captain sir our God
get out oh I can pick them up that's
right yes I'm just gonna fly around a
little bit
alright cuz that's yep doc the kids they
keep happening and capes happening
I'm not paying you guys to sit around
gettime get serious I'm serious
oh god don't fall out fleet the chef is
on the [ __ ] boat what a dick man
alright Oh Oh God
okay we're good it's all getting that
same today
alright alright steer board
sorry board forward okay boats start a
trapped man the plug a ding ding ding
hold speed ahead
it seems everything seems fine oh you
know I'm just gonna take a little toilet
break after I'm done being stuck in the
wheel of course oh [ __ ] sorry about that
tight tight tight science is gonna
I'm doing my job here you're just
sitting around yeah okay it was same
that's my hand and arm are stuck in some
way come on
yeah pace it yeah all right let's check
on that woman or whatever
all right girl what are you doing here
you're not supposed to be here
I'm sorry for stirring away please don't
throw me overboard marry me and have two
babies and I will spare you yes well now
we're both in trouble
who are you then
are we a pair save you now
now god damn it sucking dick again watch
for stowaways the whole voyage what do I
know sneak pants
how the hell are we gonna do that I'm
not an octopus down down now yet a woman
hey I need is love oh you don't see me
what places banks is here oh you have
some strong opinions
so what the [ __ ] are they talking about
oh my god I don't care and now we're
gonna get the book at that that guy's
slab out that out is that it's really
knitted too big
tell him with the belt yes yes yes [ __ ]
that's what I'm talking yet how the
swords up how does that happen
toodle-oo [ __ ] that was a close one
I hope that man is okay I hope he dies
that we're all that cool
all right all right so what about you
mystery man how are you
well someday I'll get an answer out
in the meantime make out would you care
for a dance come on make I want to see
some hentai I mean I want to see some
romance what the [ __ ]
well Isis cute isn't it
and now is stuck as an octopus
life isn't fair got after an episode
here I'll be racing watching pretty good
one never give it it I'm serious it
really it really helps and I appreciate
it if you ever do it you know we can do
it profits
you